but just
under a 4k coming through that's a one
versus one
now he's watching he sprays the box he
gets the dragon to asuna
and the ace clutch coming in starting
off at number 10 we have the golden
tones of a valorant ace
every kill results in an escalating note
that reaches a sweet
sweet crescendo
why does it sound so good maybe it's
like half of a song lyric and you just
have to finish it off each valerant note
demands the next one
pushing you on until you get that final
kill
one enemy remaining
today we're going to be talking about
satisfying moments
in esports but not just any old
satisfying moments
weirdly satisfying moments have you ever
got a
rare weapon inspect with your deagle
weirdly satisfying
ever got a happy birthday in marvel 3
weirdly satisfying
these moments often go untalked about
but for many of us
they help make the games that we're
playing so today
it's time to shine a light on them with
the top 10 weirdly satisfying moments in
esports
next up at number nine we're popping
heads left right and center with the usp
if if the coach was allowed to talk i
i'm sure he would have
probably said that you know watch out
for connector simple what's going on
three one tasks with the usb because why
not not many things can compare in cs go
to the adrenaline rush of one tapping
someone with a usp hiding in the corner
how far in are they gonna peak there's a
headshot oh my god following it up an
electronic with one of his own simple
just one for
he's eating all of them quad kill for
him oh my god
sometimes it takes a lot of skill to
pull off the one tap
other times it might just be pure luck
either way the iconic sound of the usp
kill never gets old shocks just wants
the
engagements here he wants to shoot
people in the face and he will close the
distance if he has to
look at that one bullet fired one man
down
he make it take him down from the back
though what is
shot are you serious you can't do this
[Applause]
maybe it's the silence shot followed by
the explosive squelch
that makes it such a winning combination
who would have thought that splatter
brains could sound so
[ __ ] good a storm's coming in quick
for our number eight as we have the
psionic storm from starcraft
it feels so good it will make you rip
your own clothes off
this protoss high temp plus spell
decimates enemy forces that are grouped
up
dealing massive amounts of damage and
wiping out weaker enemies
a good side storm gets everyone worked
up gonna have to try and see if he can
land another massive storm and he does
get it
those storms are huge that is so much
damaged
[Music]
[Applause]
but what makes this really satisfying is
that this aoe ability
is not the easiest to cast high templars
are slow
which is what makes the howls of enemies
caught up in the storm
that little bit more satisfying 21
marines seven medevacs eight vikings
six uh widowminds and 18 marauders
versus three high templar let's go all
right
[Laughter]
coming in at number seven we have
gaming's most iconic punch
[Music]
the falcon punch has long been one of
the most powerful special attacks in
smash bros
there is something so satisfying about
its
slow charge up time leading to a
cataclysmic punch
another spike right there
[Music]
landing a falcon punch requires time and
space
something your opponent really shouldn't
be giving you they
should see it coming a mile away that's
why it feels
so good to actually pull it off it's
humiliating for the victim
and can leave them wishing they'd never
bought the game at
all yeah but he somehow got a grab i
think he's feeling comfortable with his
three stacks
oh and the crowd erupts i think
i think that's two socks at number six
we have the highest of praises
perfect
uh stuck in his face what kind of free
free yeah
doesn't he confirm it though this time
he does
he is throwing in several golden letters
the crowd is going wild
in fighting games hearing perfect not
only means you were victorious
it means you've just smashed your
opponent without taking
a single bit of damage nice standing
strong confirmed still wearing that
samurai head
goes pretty well check out oh my
goodness
reset other side he's going to get the
stun is he going to keep the samurai hat
on the whole round
yo that's an achievement bro are you
going to owe him a
the only thing more satisfying the
fabled double perfect
clean hate no try go straight to the
super that's perfect
this man is about to take ogawa into
losers
oh my god what about it it's so close
he's got the meter
is that close is that it is that it the
keyboard
winner
blasting into number five now we have
the nitro special
it feels good to get a kill in siege by
lobbing a nitro cell at someone but
there's something
extra special about taking out multiple
enemies in one god
a three-man nitro is not just satisfying
because you've killed three people in
one go
it's the fact that it's usually a
complete surprise
you throw some c4 through a little hole
and it's like christmas has come early
and what's more satisfying than three
kills well
how about four kills to end the game
right there
can you deny the blunt
four spot we're landing five man alts
and feeling
real good about it he's gonna try and
reset it off
and not dead to the taric ultimate
defensively
[Applause]
he's gonna take you with a team by win
mmd down
landing a five-man ultimate in any game
is like the planets aligning for one
perfect moment the whole world opens up
for you
as the enemy team converges on a single
point
ppd here comes the ice blast ready for
the dog
they're gonna get away from the face of
the earth apart from aggressive
he'll jump out for the longer combo
and yes for those of you that thought i
wouldn't mention this game again
you can even dunk on five enemies at
once in smite
okay not so clean you get dirty in this
fight all the way down to 25 percent
enemy schroder the five man stunt
we're only allowed to mention smite once
a week so i hope you guys enjoyed that
one
at number three we're killing two birds
with one stone
although no birds were harmed in the
making of this video
call it collateral damage call it luck
call it whatever you
want getting two kills with one ability
always feels
so good can he get away with his life he
can he's asked he got the slam available
he knows the hair stands down and dylan
whoa here he is when enemies group up
they're basically asking for it why do
it in two shots when you can get the job
done in one
really rough game flashed he's gonna get
that shot and it has to feel a little
bit going out middle of the air
to take down alex and now they're
pushing oh
he takes every single one from nothing
to the awps sometimes
it's intentional other times it's not it
doesn't
matter collateral is collateral you're
always going to look like a god if you
can pull it off
look in the double digits face i can
certainly get it that [ __ ] guardian
keeps that up but i feel like he's
overstayed he's welcome
apparently not he's taken absolutely
everyone down with him three kills in
total
it looks like that should be here three
versus one of lucky running through
flames and my goodness what an explosive
way to close things out
we're taking a big shot in the dark for
our number two entry
no vision plays they're gonna be able to
get the bomb plant and happy even
waiting for the push in fallen
gets the spray shot anyway what
what is that have you ever landed a shot
that you had
no right to pull off i'm talking a fog
of war blindfolded
no scope kind of move the kind of play
where you can't even see what you're
aiming for
but you make a guess you pull the
trigger and hope it all pays off
whether it's a blind baron steel you are
not late game yet this is only 26
minutes in you can't
burn through this baron an 80 carry
being bottom oh my god
or even just a good old wall bang it
feels good to take a wild swing and
somehow hit a home run this is where
vitality remind themselves
there's no bomb on yet all the pressure
of the timer right now it's on a hundred
thieves and gratisfaction
oh my god are you kidding me taking down
sharks as well
and a hundred these stealing the round
[Applause]
and to finish off the video now we've
got satisfying ends to games at number
one
winning a game feels great there is no
doubt about that
sometimes though there are end game
rituals that feel
especially good oh my
he god it ending the game with a knife
kill is a
great example of this nothing humiliates
your opponent more than when you bring a
knife to a gunfight
and win he's only got 12 hp but he's
lost track of where he is the shot he's
on it
keep why is he not peak he goes for the
knife oh my goodness
you talking about config bm take that
and stick it he throws it back into a
little space a risky play but big
or in league when you get the killing
blow on the nexus
there is something so satisfying about
getting that 50 gold
even though you'll never get to spend it
or maybe even some bm fountain farming
in dota
just to rub salt in the wound thompson
he just does
not give a crap anna will give all the
life this is just
fountain farming gee you got it this is
salt breaking
[Applause]
well there you go guys i hope that left
you feeling
weirdly satisfied i have to say i felt
weirdly satisfied
just putting this video together for you
if you're still hungry for more though
don't forget to subscribe and also let
us know what you want to see next on the
channel
in the comment section below thanks for
watching and i'll see you all
in the next one i think the weirdest one
on that list for me
has to be getting the last hit on the
nexus in league
why does it give you 50 gold i've never
understood that
i saw someone on reddit said oh it's
because it's coded as an inhibitor
that doesn't make sense because
inhibitors don't give you gold either
what is going on it's been this way for
as long as i can remember
i don't know why it exists but i kind of
like it i think